euromax highlights
and here's your host kaine hemstedt
greetings from berlin and a warm welcome
to our highlights edition
and here we go with a quick look at the
top stories from the past week
seasonal sensation presenting shop
window decorations for christmas
old and new the many facets of the
island republic
of malta
and success story why the design scene
is booming in iceland
well this year november 9th marks the
24th anniversary of the fall of the
berlin wall
which was of course a momentous occasion
for postwar germany
in that it effectively signaled the end
of the communist east
well today when tourists come to berlin
they often have to search pretty hard to
find its vestiges
and so bike tours of the path that it
once traced 160 kilometers around
west berlin are very popular and we
found a guide who tries to give visitors
a feel for what it was like
in the search for traces of berlin's
divided past here only the watchtower
gives away the location of the former
border
oxford blomberg organizes bike tours
along the path of the berlin wall
he brings his groups to this memorial in
kreuzberg
it's crazy that there's a park here with
this horrible border tower in the middle
you can still see the openings where
they shot at people
the contrast is incredible the evil of
the past
and the beauty of today
this is what the border looked like that
enclosed west berlin
it's a challenge for von blumberg to
explain what it was like living in a
divided city
modern berlin takes a positive approach
to the past
the east side gallery is the perfect
example
after the wall fell in 1989 artists
painted over its once heavily fortified
eastern side
hundreds of thousands of tourists come
to visit the open air gallery every year
you get photos and stuff but not really
like we thought
you get a little view of it
but i think it's hard to really
understand how it really was
the berlin wall was built by the east
german regime in august 1961.
the border between the communist east
and the capitalist west was closely
guarded
anyone who tried to escape from the east
risked losing their lives
testimony you can see the wall wasn't
very
thick people asked how strong the wall
was
cooked when you look at the base you can
see it's very long
and there are a lot of reinforcements in
that base
that means if you drive a truck into it
here to try and break it down
you'll definitely have problems you have
to hit several segments and they weigh
more than two tons
the tour also takes groups to the former
border crossing known as checkpoint
charlie
many dramatic scenes unfolded here
during the cold war
confrontations between the soviet union
and the west
the hausam checkpoint charlie museum
documents the stories of people who fled
to the west
it also provides information about a
divided germany
i've never been to the museum but i've
often thought that what people did to
leave the country is amazing
at pot summer plots in the middle of the
new berlin stones in the ground
trace the path the wall once took
close by is brandenburg gate
once a symbol of division now it's one
of unity axel's tour ends with a visit
to the memorial on bernard
the fact that you couldn't leave left a
mark on me as a child
i wanted to show my son here in berlin
on the night the wall fell axl from
blomberg grabbed his bike and rode it
through east berlin for the first time
when i cycle along the path of the wall
it comes back to me that west berlin was
only 30 by 40 kilometers in size
the wall was right under your nose
always noticeable for westerners
the wall was 160 kilometers long and
eagle-eyed observers will be able to
spot plenty of traces of the past
even though nature is reclaiming the
land
over now to the french capital and a few
thought paris in the springtime was a
must well don't underestimate its charms
at christmas time
that's when the city lights up like a
fairy tale and the major department
stores play
an important role this past week the
famous gallery lafayette was the first
to unveil its annual christmas display
windows which are always worth
an outing in themselves
when paris's best known shopping
emporium unveils its christmas window
display
it's a grand event the boulevard
hausmann is blocked for traffic and
french actress lea cedu pushes the
button to launch the lights
afterwards she heads over to admire the
window displays accompanied by the press
and scores of visitors after all the
animated window displays are a must-see
and a paris tradition
and because it all happens on the street
we can all take part
without an invitation
we come with our family every year to
admire the displays
it's like a christmas movie every year
this year five of the 12 windows are
devoted to the beauty and the beast
fairy tale the scenes are promoting the
feature film
starring leia cedu set to open next
february
but isn't it a bit early for a christmas
display
for frederick leroux the visual identity
director at galilee lafayette
that's not a problem he's already in the
festive spirit
in january
we need almost a year to get ready this
time we developed a concept that would
appeal to children
first we sketched out the scenes and
then we decided what colors and
materials to use
and which suppliers we would order from
ep
the new display windows do have plenty
of kid appeal
they tell the story of lily the doll and
martin the teddy bear
on their journey of adventure outfitted
by star designer
marc jacobs
a cuddly teddy bear we want to appeal to
the whole family
because people come here to do shopping
for the whole family
the figures were made in this studio in
a suburb of paris
they were designed by a puppet maker and
have mechanically moving
parts the lavish decorations were a
labor of love for their maker
setting them up however can be a
challenge
some of them are two and a half by three
meters
after making them in the studio we took
them apart for transportation and
reassembled them in the display window
plus every mechanism has to work
properly
the strings on the marionettes might
tear or there might be a short circuit
it's a race against time
and there's a race among europe's
traditional department stores each year
to see who can come up with the biggest
and brightest
christmas decorations and special
promotional events
they increasingly recruit big celebrity
names including fashion designers
luxury shopping emporium harrods in
london regularly boasts top stars in
2005 american actress lucy liu
and last year british singer lily allen
it's interesting to see what others are
doing but not in the sense that you want
to win or be the best
i just want to bring our message across
i respect the competition obviously i
like to see what other stores are doing
whether theirs is the best remains to be
seen but the gallery lafayette are
definitely the first to unveil a
christmas window display
it gets earlier every year it's pretty
funny but i guess it puts you in the
holiday
i'm mood and i would advise everyone to
come and see it it's free it's beautiful
and you can see how much work went into
it
the race for the most elaborate
christmas window display is officially
on
here in paris federico is glad to have
his big day
behind him
i'm not going to say what went wrong but
80 of it worked
i think people are happy personally i'm
never satisfied with my work
but that motivates me to do even better
next year
in the meantime his work will remain on
show at the famous parisian store
until the 5th of january
the island republic of malta is one of
europe's smallest states and it's
actually made up of
three individual islands malta gozo
and kumino now home to nearly 420 000
people it's also a former british colony
and has been a member of the eu since
2004
and its very colorful history means that
it is jam-packed with culture so let's
see why
about a million tourists flock there
every year
craggy cliffs
crystal clear water
deserted landscapes dotted with tiny
villages
malta a popular holiday destination
pilot joseph gallia knows the islands
like the back of his hand
he takes visitors out for scenic tours
most days
i was always looking forward to becoming
a pilot since i was a young kid
and it was my dream job basically so i'm
there now
today's tour starts out in the capital
valletta
it's a city steeped in history
different cultures have left their mark
on malta the arabs and italians
to the french and of course the british
nasi kalamata is a local who grew up
with british influences
when we were children than to come here
on saturday morning see the changing of
the guards and see the soldiers
from scottish and irish regiments with
the bagpipes
in 1947 the islands achieved self-rule
and many brits left
malta later became independent in 1964.
the legacy of its history is its
cultural diversity
the maltese language contains arabic
italian french and
english influences
what gives us our identity is
our language so we understand each other
so well in this like secret code
and what brings us back here every time
the local cuisine also has many
different routes
chef michael kauke who has cooked for
the maltese president
runs a restaurant in palatial premises
in downtown valletta
his menus are all about fish
so now i'm preparing a local fish it's
called the
gilted head bring and then we can do a
caper
maltese traditional tomato sauce
cowheel learned to cook from his mother
and sisters
his most indispensable ingredient is
olive oil basically
the oil plays the biggest part of the
meal
i mean if it's a very good olive oil you
can feel that
every everything goes into into each
other
the best place to find quality olive oil
is on the adjacent island of gozo
a 15 minute flight away from malta
olive trees have been growing here wild
for decades
but it's only in the last 10 years that
they've been actively cultivated
by a small company called gozo cottage
dozo and malta have a 100 maritime
climate
the olives practically grow in salt with
the ocean all around
the ground is thick loamy soil which
adds a special character to the olive
oil's taste
nearby is the gigantic neolithic temple
one of the oldest open-air temples
worldwide
according to legend it was built by a
giantess in one single night
the ruins are even more stunning when
seen from the air
as our pilot joseph gallia banks around
we fly over the azure window
a natural arch formed by the collapse of
two caves
they are unique because they are natural
and especially the other window let's
say it's a big
very big place and
both of the nicest place for divers
diving is one of the most popular sports
on malta
the government has permitted diving
schools to sink old ships in order to
create
artificial reefs the overgrown wrecks
attract plenty of recreational divers
and fish
it's time for our pilot to return to the
airfield
but he'll be back in the skies tomorrow
giving tourists a special view
of his home
back in september 2008 it was in the eye
of the financial storm as it swept
europe
the island nation of iceland took a real
hit when its major banks collapsed in
the crisis
and the result was severe economic
recession
well one sector though has managed to
hold its own and even to flourish in
such difficult times and the power
of creative design is making the country
strong
reykjavik the capital of iceland the
island nation doesn't have a long
tradition of design
but over the past few years that's been
changing
art de gelgedottier of the icelandic
design center
says there's a rising demand for
homegrown products
people perhaps have been more interested
in icelandic design
they want to wear it they think it's
great they're proud of it
so p so icelanders look at it more and
i mean perhaps we were not thinking a
lot about it like in 2007 or 2006.
it's not that we didn't like it we're
just focusing on other things
fashion designer berg throughout gw has
successfully survived the economic
crisis
in 2005 she and her husband started
their farmers market label
which draws on the country's knitting
tradition
their reinterpretation of traditional
icelandic woodland jumpers hasn't just
found success on the island
but also in the rest of europe japan and
the us
when i started doing fashion or
designing
some years ago there was not so so many
icelandic designers actually working in
iceland so but now there are quite
many and people have more selection
in recent years a number of new
boutiques have opened in reykjavik
devoted to icelandic design
anyone looking for branches of major
international fashion stores on the
capitol's main shopping street will be
disappointed
places like sparks gallery sell many
creations by young designers
artle helger is on her way to the oldest
house in the city
it's home to a shop called kraum which
since 2007
sells only icelandic products
i think we are in the stage where the
designers
are exploring our roots quite a lot our
materials and
and our heritage and drawing forth
interesting stories
and materials into their design so
from my point of view we are in quite an
interesting period
right now a few hundred meters away is
the aurum boutique with adjacent studio
the work on sale here is inspired by
iceland's nature
jewelry designer both bjork christine
ingress daughter works mostly with
silver
and her customers include hollywood star
matt damon
she too came through the 2008 crisis
unscathed
actually at the same time i was
expanding i was
making myself bigger at that time so i
worry a little bit what
happened but i i just have got more
customers
the new design quarter is centered
around the capital's former fishing
harbor
several icelandic designers have moved
in and set up studios with shops
such as fashion label stanun
next door ziges is hard at work she's
one of the country's most successful
designers
the swedish furniture chain ikea is
among her clients
like many of their fellow icelandic
designers she studied and worked abroad
she only came back three years ago
people are very open-minded and there's
very short distance to everyone
if you want to make a prototype or if
you want to do something or collaborate
you only with one phone call you have it
done
that's not how it works in sweden to
further local design
the iceland academy of arts is offering
a course in product and textile design
previously young icelanders had to go
abroad to study design
and many stayed away after graduating
hatha helger wants to see an increase in
the number of
home-grown designers
icelandic music scene has emerged very
much during the last
20 to 30 years and it's a reality we
have
we have internationally acknowledged
music
musicians so why not designers
and who knows iceland's star designers
of tomorrow
might be sitting right here
well ever since she was a kid she's been
surrounded by vineyards and steeped
in family tradition regina menger krug
comes from the german state of heinlein
falls where her family is known
for producing some of this country's
best sparkling wine
now it's known as zecht in german and
it's made much the same way that
champagne is in france which makes it
just
as much of a party staple
germans love their sparkling wine it's
especially popular on birthdays and
other special occasions
regina mega cook's family has been
making sparkling wine for eight
generations
in dynasine in southwestern germany
her tip to becoming a successful vintner
victory you have to give into nature to
a certain extent
always go out no matter what the weather
is
puts her trust in mother nature roses
and more than 100 different herbs help
fertilize the soil
pesticides are strictly taboo the
vintner believes that if the grapes
don't succeed in the vineyard then
modern technology can't put them right
either
good wine growing sites are always a bit
finicky
they're like divas you have to take the
wines as they come
and you have to realize that at the
beginning they can still be a little
restless
maybe from fermentation but that
eventually calms down
they just need a little more time they
need tender loving care
the way we women like it right
the fine wine maturing in these barrels
riesling
chardonnay pinot blanc and pinot noir
will later become sparkling wine
begina menger krug's secret is her
moonwood barrels made from
trees felled as the moon was waning
the famous violin maker stradivari swore
by moonwood too
the wood is fine these barrels are like
a cradle for the wine
it's astonishing everyone is amazed by
how it works
a great deal of love and patience goes
into each bottle
the mega kook vineyard makes sparkling
wine the classic french way like
champagne
the wine ferments with yeast in the
bottle for nine months to
two years then the yeast is removed
this wine has been fermenting for more
than 30 years and it's still drinkable
it's also fascinating that as long as
the yeast remains in the wine
the sparkling wine doesn't age the yeast
is like a fountain of youth
the 500 year old enterprise is a
traditional family operation
i was very lucky with my parents because
they raised me simply as a person and
not as a girl
it was a gender-neutral upbringing i was
taught i could achieve whatever i wanted
the number of women vintners is on the
rise but three generations
is a rarity regina menger kook's mother
is over 90 but still actively involved
and soon daughter marie will take over
a lot will remain the same because my
parents have done a great job
some people i studied with have had
conflicts with the older generation
but my parents have stayed young and fit
they'll be happy to work another 50
years
practical knowledge passed down the
generations and attention to nature
those are the secrets of the success of
regina menger
outstanding sparkling wines
and that is all for this edition of our
euromax highlights and be sure to visit
our website or perhaps
our facebook page if you'd like to catch
up on some of those reports again
otherwise until we meet again all the
best and thanks for watching
cheers
you